unfortunately for the couples who look
like they could use his help he's busy
with a brand new project this is my
first podcast ever it's very odd casting
him why are you doing a podcast I get to
talk to interesting people about
interesting things when dr. Phil sits
down with celebrities
he uses his shrink skills to dig deep
I'd say I've I've had what could maybe
be called a sex addiction at some point
in my life the show was called fill in
the blanks and he got Shaquille O'Neal
to open up about his painful past I know
a lot of people had tough childhoods
mine was a very tough he shared with me
the fact that he could not read until he
was in the ninth grade why are you not
tired o ask the questions around here
who was the one person you want to get I
want to talk to OJ before he dies hmm
but it was time to turn the tables on
the good doctor I put him through a
little game we're also calling fill in
the blanks the star you had a crush on
growing up Wow there Farrah Fawcett I'm
sure the star robbing currently has a
crush on that be a rod all right and you
have won the celebrity that would leave
you starstruck
Dolly Parton I hope she watches this I
want to talk to you we're soul mates
we've got to do this
[Music]